[MUSIC PLAYING]
Last episode, we used a
decision tree as our classifier.
Today we'll add
code to visualize it
so we can see how it
works under the hood.
There are many
types of classifiers
you may have heard of before--
things like neural nets
or support vector machines.
So why did we use a
decision tree to start?
Well, they have a
very unique property--
they're easy to
read and understand.
In fact, they're one of the few
models that are interpretable,
where you can understand
exactly why the classifier makes
a decision.
That's amazingly
useful in practice.
To get started,
I'll introduce you
to a real data set
we'll work with today.
It's called Iris.
Iris is a classic
machine learning problem.
In it, you want to identify
what type of flower
you have based on
different measurements,
like the length and
width of the petal.
The data set includes three
different types of flowers.
They're all species of
iris-- setosa, versicolor,
and virginica.
Scrolling down,
you can see we're
given 50 examples of each
type, so 150 examples total.
Notice there are four
features that are
used to describe each example.
These are the length and
width of the sepal and petal.
And just like in our
apples and oranges problem,
the first four columns give the
features and the last column
gives the labels, which is the
type of flower in each row.
Our goal is to use this data
set to train a classifier.
Then we can use that classifier
to predict what species
of flower we have if we're given
a new flower that we've never
seen before.
Knowing how to work with
an existing data set
is a good skill, so let's
import Iris into scikit-learn
and see what it
looks like in code.
Conveniently, the
friendly folks at scikit
provided a bunch of
sample data sets,
including Iris, as
well as utilities
to make them easy to import.
We can import Iris into
our code like this.
The data set includes
both the table
from Wikipedia as
well as some metadata.
The metadata tells you
the names of the features
and the names of different
types of flowers.
The features and
examples themselves
are contained in
the data variable.
For example, if I print
out the first entry,
you can see the measurements
for this flower.
These index to the feature
names, so the first value
refers to the sepal length,
and the second to sepal width,
and so on.
The target variable
contains the labels.
Likewise, these index
to the target names.
Let's print out the first one.
A label of 0 means
it's a setosa.
If you look at the
table from Wikipedia,
you'll notice that we just
printed out the first row.
Now both the data and target
variables have 150 entries.
If you want, you can
iterate over them
to print out the entire
data set like this.
Now that we know how to
work with the data set,
we're ready to
train a classifier.
But before we do that, first
we need to split up the data.
I'm going to remove
several of the examples
and put them aside for later.
We'll call the examples I'm
putting aside our testing data.
We'll keep these separate
from our training data,
and later on we'll use
our testing examples
to test how accurate
the classifier is
on data it's never seen before.
Testing is actually a
really important part
of doing machine learning
well in practice,
and we'll cover it in more
detail in a future episode.
Just for this exercise,
I'll remove one example
of each type of flower.
And as it happens,
the data set is
ordered so the first
setosa is at index 0,
and the first versicolor
is at 50, and so on.
The syntax looks a little bit
complicated, but all I'm doing
is removing three entries from
the data and target variables.
Then I'll create two new
sets of variables-- one
for training and
one for testing.
Training will have the
majority of our data,
and testing will have just
the examples I removed.
Now, just as before, we
can create a decision tree
classifier and train it
on our training data.
Before we visualize
it, let's use the tree
to classify our testing data.
We know we have one
flower of each type,
and we can print out
the labels we expect.
Now let's see what
the tree predicts.
We'll give it the features
for our testing data,
and we'll get back labels.
You can see the predicted
labels match our testing data.
That means it got
them all right.
Now, keep in mind, this
was a very simple test,
and we'll go into more
detail down the road.
Now let's visualize
the tree so we can
see how the classifier works.
To do that, I'm
going to copy-paste
some code in from
scikit's tutorials,
and because this code
is for visualization
and not machine-learning
concepts,
I won't cover the details here.
Note that I'm combining the
code from these two examples
to create an easy-to-read PDF.
I can run our script
and open up the PDF,
and we can see the tree.
To use it to classify data, you
start by reading from the top.
Each node asks a
yes or no question
about one of the features.
For example, this node
asks if the pedal width
is less than 0.8 centimeters.
If it's true for the example
you're classifying, go left.
Otherwise, go right.
Now let's use this tree
to classify an example
from our testing data.
Here are the features and label
for our first testing flower.
Remember, you can
find the feature names
by looking at the metadata.
We know this flower is
a setosa, so let's see
what the tree predicts.
I'll resize the windows to
make this easier to see.
And the first
question the tree asks
is whether the petal width
is less than 0.8 centimeters.
That's the fourth feature.
The answer is true,
so we proceed left.
At this point, we're
already at a leaf node.
There are no other
questions to ask,
so the tree gives us
a prediction, setosa,
and it's right.
Notice the label is 0, which
indexes to that type of flower.
Now let's try our
second testing example.
This one is a versicolor.
Let's see what
the tree predicts.
Again we read from the top,
and this time the pedal width
is greater than 0.8 centimeters.
The answer to the tree's
question is false,
so we go right.
The next question the tree
asks is whether the pedal width
is less than 1.75.
It's trying to narrow it down.
That's true, so we go left.
Now it asks if the pedal
length is less than 4.95.
That's true, so
we go left again.
And finally, the tree
asks if the pedal width
is less than 1.65.
That's true, so left it is.
And now we have our
prediction-- it's a versicolor,
and that's right again.
You can try the last one
on your own as an exercise.
And remember, the way
we're using the tree
is the same way
it works in code.
So that's how you quickly
visualize and read
a decision tree.
There's a lot more
to learn here,
especially how they're built
automatically from examples.
We'll get to that
in a future episode.
But for now, let's close
with an essential point.
Every question the tree
asks must be about one
of your features.
That means the better your
features are, the better a tree
you can build.
And the next episode
will start looking
at what makes a good feature.
Thanks very much for watching,
and I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]